bonjour à tous bienvenue dans le résumé
des ondes 11 et 12 du match de
championnat du monde dans cette 11e
partie magnus carsen avec les blancs
rejoint le coup eux quatre pour la
deuxième fois dans le match et bien
entendu fabiano caruana je vois sa
défense favorite la défense petrov nous
atteignons cette position 11e coup pour
les noirs les noirs viennent de jouer
fou e6 nous attendions à une partie d'
attaque puisque les blancs avec le grand
roque contre le petit rock aurait pu
essayer de mener donc une avancée du
pion probablement sur le roi noir
cette position était connu une partie
avait été jouée avec le coup j'ai cinq
sur lesquels noir faisait probablement
ont fait une erreur avec le couac chis
ce qui est permis aux blancs de
sacrifier le fond analyse et d'obtenir
une bonne attaque finalement et dans la
partie et zur une tour et trois pions
contre deux pièces mineurs probablement
sur le beauf ou g simple deuxième coulée
noire aurait joué plutôt le coût des
cinq dans la partie entre même ce
qu'arsène et fabiano caruana
nous eûmes droit aux coups 12,3 b1 et
après damas cinq qui est menacée
évidemment le pion à 2
le coup probablement forcé c4 nous faire
entrer dans déjà dans une finale après
dun prend des deux fous prend des deux
peut être il ya un petit avantage pour
les blancs à cause du pion arriérés des
noirs en d6 mais les noirs vont vite
réussir à échanger les pièces
ashes cavaillé h4h 4 dans l'idée d'aller
prendre la paire de fou avec le coup
cavaliers f5 toro 8 pour libérer une
case pour le fou au 7 mai après
cavaliers g6 joli coup puisque si les
noirs prennent le cahier rouge et 6 le
fou et s'y serait pris et dans ces cas
là les blancs obtiendrait enfin la paire
de faux les noirs on le fera aussi
cavalier gkd qui permet de simplifier
complètement la situation cavaillé
procède tout reprend 1,7 le pion f2 et
en attaque et les blancs doivent le
protéger avec tours 2 et cavaye 5 force
les changes des fous après faut être
quatre epr en d3 tourcoing des trois
tours des celtes pour l'existant pour
des six coupons des six taureaux des
huit tours d2 floup ans et quatre mois
c'est un v6 faut être calme tamponnais
de reprendre et de voilà on obtient une
position complètement égal et mais
pourtant la partie va continuer encore
assez assez loin donc on va passer très
rapidement cette suite qui n'a pas
beaucoup d'importance les noirs
finalement c'est kéfi un pion dans
l'acte final de toute façon avec les
foules couleurs opposées même avec un
pion - on peut facilement tenir la
position et bloquer les pions passer des
blancs c'est ce qui va se passer mais il
va y avoir quand même une façon
intéressante de jouer avec les noirs
alors les blancs qui ont un pion passé
du côté dames
qui est bloquée bien sûr puisque l'on
peut pas passer sur casse blanche vont
tenter du côté droit d'essayer de créer
un pion passé mais avec trois pions
contre 3 évidemment ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas possible pourtant avec l'aide
du roi il ya une possibilité si les
noirs ne font pas attention
après j'ai 4 h projet 4 pour gta tri 6 x
2 roger 5 le roi va se poster en f6 pour
attaquer plus bref cet après le plan des
blancs va être d'essayer de dévier le
pion g6 pour qu'ils prennent le pion en
f 5,6 à ce moment là le pion g6 prend en
rêve 5
évidemment le pion h4 pourrait avancer
et on pourrait créer un deuxième plan
passé qui permettrait de gagner la
partie mais les noirs évidemment ne
prennent pas en 9 5 et joue le très bon
coup mais un les blancs font un coude
attentes et les noirs aussi il n'y a
rien à faire avec les blancs évidemment
si on perd on apprend f7 le flou prend
au f5 et y en a jamais deux pions pas ch
à noter que si les noirs avaient pris le
pion f5 avec le fou ce serait une grosse
erreur parce que les blancs auraient pu
jouer à chat dans ces cas là et sur
pyongyang le fou au f5 était perdu voilà
le dernier piège était ici là ne l'a été
conclu après le coût 55 pouces et deux
dans cette 12e partie maintenant dans
laquelle fabiano caruana cette fois
avait les blancs et c'était la dernière
chance pour l'un des deux joueurs de
gagner une partie dans
le match en classique s'est dernièrement
partie longue donc on rejoint à nouveau
une variante sicilienne schennikov dans
lequel le coup sept cavaliers des cinq a
été jouée pour la troisième fois par
fabiano caruana
et cette fois c'est magnus carsen qui va
changer avec le point 8 cavaliers aux 7
qui est l'autre alternative il avait
préféré par deux fois le coût calibre
des 8
ça va peut-être un petit peu surpris son
adversaire qui s'attendait pas c'est de
suite de coups et magnus carlsen a même
joué une nouveauté avec le coup de 12 h
5 ici qui vient d'être jouée alors on
voit le gouffre est sain il jouer parce
que il ya eu une répétition de position
après damas quatre fous 17 d'un b4y 5
voilà les blancs ont répété les coûts
probablement pour gagner du temps à la
pendule parce que les blancs étaient
dans une position nouvelle apparemment
dans laquelle il a préféré le coup fouet
3 le coucou g5 qui ont été un peu plus
logique probablement il n'a pas voulu
rentrer dans la préparation son
adversaire il a préféré jouer fou hull 3
donc développement classique et normale
mais attaque le pion en ascète là bas
avec le foie le cavalier donc elle si
c'est un coût relativement logique
cavaillé ces trois dames c'est cette un
coût attendu pour défendre tout
simplement le pion bessette
il était peut-être possible de le
sacrifier à anjouan le coup fou 7 et sur
dame prend 17 tout simplement le petit
rock et de jouer avec lui pion de retard
mais le coup d'essai c'est un coup
totalement raisonnable évidemment pour
les noirs j'ai trois coups aussi attendu
pour défendre le pion h4 est contrôlée
1,15 f4 pour éviter que le cavalier g6
ne puisse bouger x 7 et là un coup en
relativement inattendue quand même le
coup f3 s'attendaient plutôt au cou aux
deux tout simplement d'après et qu'il
est sur cavani et fuite alors l'idée de
fouet aux deux c
aussi le pion à chaque don qu'il y avait
des fuites est plutôt forcé afin de
ramener le cavalier qui mal placé et qui
ce qui permettra par la suite de venir
défendre se pliant à chaque soit en
mettant le fond j'ai six soirs en
poussant le pion angers 6 voilà et la
suite petit rock qui avait 17 par
exemple tour à ses seins et semblait
tout à fait correct pour les blancs avec
un petit plus certainement le coeff trop
a été assez étonnant un peu affaiblie
sans cavalier fuite a été joué cavalier
ou quatre ça c'était l'idée du coup f3
pour amener ce qui a veillé au centre
mais finalement ce qui a éveillé peut se
faire chasser assez facilement cavaliers
17 fou détroit petit rock les noirs
n'ont pas peur de donner la paire de fou
avec avaya finissait avec suivi de foot
pro f 5 parce qu'ils obtiendraient un
bon contre eux je centrale et là on
aurait pu s'attendre au cou tout
simplement petit rock avec les blancs
même si la position durant est un peu
affaibli ça semblait assez jouable
encore élu le coup 21 tours h2 goût
assez surprenant finalement les blancs
décide de faire passer leur tour sur les
dames est probablement le roi va venir
sur les dames aussi avec le grand roque
donc ça c'est assez assez surprenants
comme comme idée plutôt douteux
probablement parce que finalement ce
sont les noirs qui vont tenir une belle
initiative rectorat ses 8 ans rock foo
g6 tour ces deux voilà c'est assez
original de passer la tour devant le
rôle comme ça l'idée des blancs savez le
hall de confort c'est ce côté dames
c'est elle dame pour essayer de se créer
un pion passé mais ce sont des noirs qui
vont avoir la tacc on est quand même
dans une position avec des rock ou poser
à nouveau un pour la deuxième fois de
suite
et dans ces cas là
la taxe sur le roi est souvent le mail
le meilleur plan mais la façon de jouer
c'est souvent d'avancé les pions devant
le roi adverse pour ouvrir des lignes
dès lors faire on fait f100 et pour
chasser le cavalier voilà ce que lui
disait qu'il y avait eu 4 ne pouvait pas
rester longtemps
cavaye f2 cavaillé c5f 4 pour essayer de
fixer un petit peu le fou de cases
blanches des noirs qui est maintenant un
peu bloqué derrière ses pions sauf qu'il
va pouvoir repartir un se fout de
l'autre côté on par la case du 8 et
ensuite peut-être même venir sur un 4 1
pour créer des menaces sur contre le jeu
des blancs alors le coup à saint qui a
été jouée pour chasser la dame d'amd 2e
4 oui j'en aurais pu s'attendre aussi à
la beaucoup offrant f4 qui était
intéressant afin d'ouvrir un petit peu
le jeu sur au centre afin d'installer le
fond f6 mais éventuellement de jouer
aussi sur laquelle de 4 avec lecavalier
mais le cou aux 4 et semble quand même
un bon coup puisque le pion devient un
pion passé protéger un an capillon très
fort dans la finale mais dans le bios de
partis aussi très intéressant puisqu'il
bloc assez facilement le cavalier blanc
qui a plus beaucoup de cases maintenant
donc là on pensait vraiment on posera
donc il ya un bon avantage pour les
noirs après x 2 x 8 voilà le fou qui se
replacent robe et un fouet f6 l'autre
fou maintenant qui s'activent sur cette
belle diagonale on pouvait s'attendre au
bout des 4 1 pour essayer d'échanger le
fou mais finalement c'est un mauvais
coup parce qu'après fou à 4 qui a taclé
de tournon qui forcent coup b3 pour
éviter de perdre activités il y a une
petite pointe fou prend b3 puis en
tomber trois cavaliers prend b3 et le
cavalier fait une fourchette sur la dame
est sûre le fou donc les noirs gagne du
matériel
on pourrait on pourrait être même
continuer avec dams et trois cavaliers
prend des quatre tours prend des cadres
et dans le pays six échecs voilà les
noirs sont même pas obligé de donner
leurs fous pour prendre la tour donc
évidemment la partie la pollution est
complètement gagnant pour les noirs ici
donc après fouille 6les veux bien tout
cas loin d'un haut tombe pas dans le
piège
évidemment et joue autour de 1 à 4 voilà
les noirs qui tentent de d'ouvrir une
colonne sur le roi blanc peut-être joué
à troyes après mais c'est aussi dans
l'idée parfois d'amener le cahier en b3
sacrifices pour faire jouer en mettant
après leur retour ou avant plutôt la
tour ou à 8 pour venir attaquer sur le
roi qu'il ya des motifs de combinaisons
c'est pour ça qu'il est blanc joue le
coup d'un v4 pour contrôler la case en
b3 et pour protéger aussi un petit peu
elle dame g6 tout simplement les coups
un coup solide 1 pour défendre le pion
h5 afin de libérer le fou de la défense
du pion éventuellement la possibilité
pour la dame de revenir en batteries
derrière le fou tour d un les blancs
temps de d'essayer de jouer le courroux
des quatre tours à huit un bon coup
probablement afin de de coulisses et en
asie et en b 6 et là de façon très
surprenante magnus carlsen propose à la
nulle dans cette position alors que les
noirs quand même semblait avoir un bon
avantage en plus il veut aussi un
avantage autant
bon il préfère jouer les départage
peut-être est-ce un bon calcul pour lui
c'est vrai qu'il a qui les a priori
meilleurs en partie rappelez nous
verrons bien
mercredi prochain puisque là ce sera le
jour des départage
merci beaucoup d'avoir suivi s'est
résumé de ce championnat du monde est
et je vous dis j'espère que ça vous a
plu et je vous dis à bientôt sur chaque
point comme merci